now do you remember the movie two birds
do you try to wake up y'all come on now
all right I want to recreate a moment
from that film
okay so that was the bird
now comes the cage he won an Oscar for
leaving Las Vegas and now he's here
tonight in 70-millimeter ladies and
gentlemen
Academy Award winner Nicolas Cage
for film producers the one honor that's
more coveted than Oscar is Irving this
is the Irving G Thalberg award in 70
years only 33 of them have been granted
to producers whose high quality of their
movies was consistent this year the
Academy Board of Governors has
recognized the superior craftsmanship of
a man who is currently producing and
directing his 26 film his name is Norman
Jewison
and his work has received 12 Oscars and
41 Academy Award nominations so far
among his triumphs are landmark films of
humanity here are some reminders of his
work ladies and gentlemen the Irving G
Thalberg award recipient mr. Norman
Jewison
right right not bad for a [ __ ]
what do you say Irving 40 they really
keep this this show going there 40 years
of filmmaking and they does it in three
minutes
it's well everything you're one heavy
dude this is you want to hold him he's
about 20 pounds there's a lot of people
to thank of course but Irving once said
that brevity is a great virtue so I
accept this great honor tonight and the
names of all those people who have
contributed to my work my life's work 40
years ago I sat at William Wyler's feet
and tried to learn how to make movies
and Willy wallet was a god to me and he
won this award and I think that's what
is so meaningful to me to join all those
filmmakers that have gone before I would
like to thank my immediate loved ones my
family every actor writer editors
cinematographer production designer
costume designer sound man and editor
I've ever worked with all those crews in
Europe and Canada in the United States
and my one real regret about winning
this prize is that you know it's not
like the Nobel or the Pulitzer I mean
the Thalberg award comes with no money
attached
I if it did if it did I would share it
with the Canadian film center in the AFI
we're the next generation of filmmakers
are preparing to entertain the world in
the new millennium and my parting
thought to all those young filmmakers is
this just find some good stories
never mind the grouse the top ten bottom
ten what's the rating what's the
demographic just
you know something the biggest grossing
picture is not necessarily the best
picture I want to tell you something so
just tell stories that move us to
laughter in tears and perhaps reveal a
little truth about ourselves and as for
myself I hope to see you again next year
Helen Hunt and the Oscar for Best Actor
will be coming up next stay with us